one of us just needs to say a complete
sentence deal let's see who can do it
first that's the game Courtney is a chef
she's also one of my best friends and
she's written so many cookbooks worked
in incredible famous kitchens we're so
lucky to have her on the show Making
Elizabeth food let's begin shall
[Music]
we you and I have been friends for what
thousand years oh maybe more that to say
we've been friends for a very long time
and food has been a very big part of it
we get together with people to make
something that then fuels and sustains
mhm you so today we're going to make the
lasagna the lasagna the lasagna from
lessons in chemistry yes and lasagna is
comforting and loving and requires a lot
of time and energy and uh ultimately
this is the beginning of the Elizabeth
and celvin relationship this is one of
the first things he tastes that
Elizabeth makes I think he falls in love
at first bite wow that's perfect it's
not perfect but it has the potential to
be how do you think Lou is going to do
making it you think he's going to be
okay I think he's going to be good at
the assembly yeah I think he can
assemble he can follow directions he's
going to love eating it he's definitely
going to love eating as will I and you
definitely me we should probably go make
it soon let's make
it before we get started pray tell who
is your character in the show oh I play
Elizabeth zot uh who is a scientist and
then later has a cooking show Welcome
viewers my name is Elizabeth zot and
this is supper at
six I play Calvin Evans Calvin Evans is
a star smart well to-do famous what's
not to like is a chemist and doesn't
really have a future in
cooking until today until today until
today right so we're going to we're
making lasagna it's based on the lasagna
from the show but this is an even more
amped up lasagna um it has homemade
pasta dough the thinnest layers possible
it's going to be like 12 layers and
lucky for y'all I went ahead and already
made the dough and then I also made the
bamel for it so we're going to focus
today on the bolog sauce okay starting
now Bri I would like you to do the
honors go ahead in oil you're going to
put oil in the pan and then add the Mir
POA everything but the
garlic so we're just going to sauté this
down let's go ahead and add the meat
how's that sound yeah what kind of meat
so this is another reason why this B is
so delicious this is ground pork ground
pinetta and then we have ground beef so
go ahead and toss that into the old pan
okay just throw it all into the
trampoline here yeah
yeah so your characters on the show are
to very passionate humans like you're
passionate about rowing you're
passionate about cooking chemistry all
of these passions you have you also
share them with each other so how does
that deepen your relationship when they
meet each other and they're able to talk
on this level about science in
particular and then when Elizabeth
starts cooking for Calin then it creates
this this language I mean the first time
that they really started to connect is
over her talking about lasagna at about
92° the solid milk fat and the cheese
liquefies and the bonds holding together
the casin proteins break but the Melt
isn't smooth which is why I've been
experimenting with sodium citrate so
when the cheese Heats proteins separate
from each other acting as an M of fires
precisely I think a big part of that
when when they meet and kind of
discovering how Elizabeth looks at
cooking is this is a great kind of
metaphor and microcosm for their
relationship as a whole because he sees
food as just like sustenance and brain
power you have one fork I don't
entertain and so then all of a sudden
that you can apply chemistry and it can
be you you can go into a real micro lens
on it and and kind of like they're
really nerding out on it Elizabeth and
Calvin are nerds of a Feather you cooked
for me I can't promise it'll taste as
good as yours but but was edible this a
lovely steam bath we're getting soon it
is yeah I'm feeling a nice get a nice
facial good for skin yeah every time I
cook I I'm reminded of my grandmother
because she would every time she cracks
an egg would take her long fingernails
and scrape every little molecule of yolk
out of there she grew up in the
depression and like with her with her
nail yeah and I do that I carry that
tradition on with your long fingernail
do you have a long do you have a long
finger just a
pinky well and actually lasagna reminds
me of my grandma because that's what she
would do she would make it and then like
the best thing was the next day The
Leftovers reheating the
leftovers now we're going to assemble so
the first layer is is this bolog and
then we're going to put a layer of
noodles a really thin layer of the bamal
a little bit of Parmesan a little bit of
the bolog and then every third or fourth
layer we're going to dollop a little
tiny bit of Ricotta and then we're
saving the mozzarella for the very top
layer so it'll be nice and bubbly and
cheesy I'm going to put it in the oven
thank you get ready
bye lasagna see you by Las we love you
thank
you while on is baking I just have a few
random questions mhm um we're going to
start with one of my favorites an
asteroid is headed straight to Earth you
have about you have about one day got a
day yeah and you have one meal oh what
are you going to eat mine would be a
baked potato with a lot of butter
fluffed very well okay sour cream C yeah
that's a good one I would do my mom's
apple crisp with some ice cream this is
great knowledge to have yeah it's
important it's important knowledge the
most important knowledge though and I'm
sorry I have to ask this but you know I
have to this a hot dog a sandwich I
forget where you both stand on this I
know which is why you got to go first
you got you got to just do what's true
for you and I think if you have two
pieces of bread with something in the
middle of it there's nothing else to
call it other than a sandwich yes that's
what I
think Bri do you not agree with of
course I don't agree with it Courtney of
course I don't agree with it it's been
going on it's been going on for years
it's been going on for years people it's
been going on for years this is the
thing that we don't talk about in our
relationship because this might drive us
apart I love you very much we'll leave
it at that okay love
[Music]
you the lasagna can you smell
it gosh I can't and Wow Let's Get it I
think it's done nothing better than
smell of fresh lasagna holy moly yeah
look at this look at the bubble it's
free bird free a bird free a bird thank
you yeah voila oh my goodness gor Mama
Mia Mama Mia wow
yeah I'm just going to go in go
ready oh my God this is so satisfying
who does this ever we do now
wow wow courney nailed it that is a
superior lasagna oh man we did
it y'all seriously thank you so much for
coming out taking the time to do this
day it was so much fun I loved making
lasagna with you it was the best
absolute best Courtney we couldn't have
had a better Sensei thank you thank you
yeah thanks fry yeah my pleasure and if
you want to learn more about their
characters and this lasagna you can
watch lessons in chemistry on Apple TV
plus all right I'm going to take this
[Music]
home